previously on the walking bill there's
somebody one of us out there he or she
or they have been taking [ __ ] stop
putting your booty slipping them our
meds they didn't get their last package
so they attending you think you're some
tough [ __ ] don't you doesn't hurt you
but you're just a scared little girl get
the [ __ ] over it I'll die out here I
don't feel it all right
wowie how's it going breath my name is
Brianna by gravity turn into zombie
what's up with that I'll never let her
die explode
I'm not kidding if comi dies I'm not
playing this game anymore
now we got a deal with this
oh [ __ ]
another problem huh we could just drive
around you know
is there any way to get around it
doesn't look like it on foot maybe can't
really afford to do that now huh this
seems like a safe area this brush will
stop anything from creeping up on us
[Music]
as much as I hate that little piece of
[ __ ] why don't you and I go look around
yeah everyone else relax
clear stay close to Kitty and Kat okay
Lee if you come across anything to drink
if there's a dining car or something
I think ducks a bit dehydrated it's a
frayed room be careful in there what you
think there might be something dangerous
inside an abandoned locomotive across my
mind I felt I felt I felt complex
I felt really complex I mean I hate
dying but he's just a boy and I don't
know it's kind of sad
why would he have done with it I don't
know
laughter I've never seen anybody kill
someone like that that is crazy you've
seen a butcher of this stuff right now
yeah but not like that
I agree was it you bastard you not this
again was it no okay all right it been
you uh happy you stayed with us all this
time
yeah really it's with you guys are dead
I would have died out there in the woods
just like my classmates I think this is
better yeah of course
all righty then let's check the
locomotive would have shoes I love shoes
mister Charlotte's really puffy why well
somebody's been living it yeah man she
think they're gone I hope so but this
looks recently used be on the lookout
and have you got on all right then
I'm Matt
I think that map of where the train goes
I think these tracks might lead to the
coast o7 Silvana
that's where kidneys got us headed all
right we'll keep that then uh I guess
don't get this - Cujo for Doug I guess
we can get ya why does everything gotta
turn so bad everything was fine at the
motor and jump all right what do we got
over here
hey go okay I can go ahead yeah and
Carly's dead
no one even gives a [ __ ] now we got a
bunch of tools in leaves
we can use this for zombie killing it's
my reaction as well all right so I got
it I can't have to it once I guess that
makes a little sense
all right let's hope I don't have to go
back there what are we getting
absolute mint onion glad that thing is
this all right so there's three doors
check this one then sorry four doors
what do we got
it doesn't work I can offer I don't know
you put on the locomotive here it's
quite the big engine I guess it makes
sense
oh here's the engine compartment what
nothing
really all right fine see if I care
it's locked
[ __ ] oh we got one
Walker sitting in the chair we got him
all right the gun nor the I'm gonna use
the wrench hi bag I'll chop aiyah Doan I
just wanted to meet you the guys already
been suppose we look him over
yeah how you doing there sir nice face
bro damn someone shoot him I don't think
this guy came back Christ that light is
blinking what does that mean push it
push it
amazing are you [ __ ] serious here
look
it's just the brakes okay I'll give you
that no it works seems like it I'll be
damned
how the hell do we get it moving I don't
know
that's mr. Ram check over here no clue
we found this in the boxcar back there
whoa is this what it looks like yeah
take us through the Cubs hostel take us
right to Savannah a hundred tons of
Steel what a thousand walkers between us
in the ocean we don't have to give a
[ __ ] I can't believe it
and what about dr. Bob Doc what about it
well he's invented like nothing to
happen to him we can't act like he's
dead either okay fair enough
you said get this thing started there's
gotta be some sort of a manual or
something Kenny I don't know about that
that's the spirit
Kenny I think if she's got better if you
could keep an eye on the girls and duck
I'd appreciate it I'm gonna make sense
of these controls Kenny you should
really go to your sang man this could be
exactly what we need
can't tell him thank you
what's up you want to talk about that
I'm really sorry Kenny nobody deserves
this there's nothing to talk about
you heard Kat he could be fine we
probably shouldn't ignore nobody's
ignoring nothing I'm not worried you
shouldn't be either Kenny
good night some hope good mystery girls
get the train going then take notes
right when working on stuff like this
we're smart guys we can figure it out
yeah don't delay
all right back to it me too I can get
that little thing Bo two myths about
Georgia City's about this
what about that's it this is it
instructions on starting the engine it's
so uncheck it ages ago invitations find
a way to read the indentation right the
lunge huh
that's nasty bra my things got to be so
complicated
still me white hats being a rape thing
so complicated
see there Wade Lee is spending like is
wrapping it with me forever ma'am ma'am
ma'am I know I'm singing that song I'm
really sorry I need to find a magnifying
glass
maybe maybe clement asked one that's not
cloudy
there's a notepad on the train do you
have any pencils or anything in your
pack no I wish maybe an erv what do you
need it for
there used to be something written on
the notepad that I need to know about
well if you're not using it I take it
I'm out of paper and there's all sorts
of new leaves around here alright okay
we don't really have time for that right
now though alright I guess I give you
the bathtub oh it's warm
oh thank you he's allergic to bees is
that right
it's all I can keep thinking about like
somehow that matters it doesn't I know
well I don't but you're probably right
all right she's thankful huh it's not
gonna change anything that's what the
hell of it this yeah we're not even sure
if it's gonna get moving or not why did
the train stop here anyway it's got to
be something here
no no no I don't want to go here maybe
we can check the other side and we came
from that right I go in the wrong side
what am I not it's not gonna way I could
definitely pry this thing free if I
could break it loose first I guess we
got to do that [ __ ] broker well [ __ ] we
can't do much then can we do you rails
that all we can do here all right I
guess we go back then Brad this is
really really a really really really
really slow game play but hey Lee is
jumping around and it's stretching so
that's good maybe we need another tool I
don't think that's gonna change anything
you need like one of those Kip sirs our
prep sir who what happens if we go here
why don't we get it's in pretty good
shape for a wreck
hey Bambi [ __ ] you MA fine I'll make out
with you this doors gonna hurt
[Applause]
well what am I supposed to do that you
gonna like this hello come on okay
that's what you get for scaring me
yeah what disgusting
don't come back alive leave
I can hit jump scares I don't what am I
doing with animal crackers I did all
that for animal crackers it's like are
you serious
well you got to do what you got it there
huh [ __ ] animal crackers what's over
here something over here Oh kids you
guys well once animal crackers here
fellas
if Ducks up for thank you that's very
thoughtful
he isn't fussy you know what most kids
they're really fussy about what they
lead hate vegetables that kind of thing
is me know the most trouble I ever have
is making him use a fork Thank You Lee
sure god damn it
I can't turn the steam up it's really
annoying oh well I'm sorry
anyway let's check the van all right we
need a pencil that's a magazine the
drawers nada nada
what I have it a pencil yeah all right
let's solve that little issue what do I
have I do something else here banana
drink I love banana drink Clementine
solves it again another reason why she
saw us
let's get that pencil off and find the
engine extractions [ __ ] all the [ __ ]
I go through to stay back are you just
sitting there
really Jesus Christ man all the steps to
get the engine off sounds good well
alright what is this am I supposed to
remember all this number 6 down down up
up down up down down up up down up down
down up down down up how do I look at
this again hello I don't remember number
6 right all right down down up down up
down
oh [ __ ] down down up I think that was my
remember is the best ever
yeah oh [ __ ] I got it wrong I don't like
I'm a lot guy there we go
is this gonna turn green or something
son of a [ __ ] whatever you did let the
dash up so that was for rubbing my
nipple did it it it it number 5 to the
left to the down I don't even know left
down yeah we're talking we're talking
where my pain is girl
[Laughter]
how do i click alright so nine is just
to their right and today pretty
straightforward the [ __ ] is nine why did
I go outside five six seven eight
where's nine it's got to be the main
engine wasn't this the engine control
room that it this is not the right
Locker I think we'll need this
got 11 all right yeah gal engine
compartment here we go brother so first
first to the right and enter line right
what did I say ah easy [ __ ]
we're golden doc doc what about look
it's something we're gonna have to deal
with did you not hear cat we don't know
[ __ ] Lee let's [ __ ] enjoy this
mom let's see if she'll move
fine then
well we gotta kiss up the rabbit all
yours
[Music]
damnit
of course we're still attached can you
go find out where we're stuck get us
unstuck well maybe you should do
something every once in a while I'm fine
all right let's get this unstuck and
then I'm gonna end this episode actually
here we go
happy go jump Lee jump I think I have
the right tool now I don't see how you
can do with any other tools
[Music]
all right it's passed through
I don't see how you do it with this tool
either though but I guess we don't have
my shot of the choice holy [ __ ] it way
Jane Eyre Spacek Jane we use the knife
that's a vetted in the knife
[Music]
you touching my stuff ha gotta end this
episode here like a baby if you enjoyed
subscribe to read today not see any
[Music]
[ __ ] lady [ __ ] stupid [ __ ]